Spurs
Cavs
heat
Clippers
They're all just spokes on a wheel
This one's on [top] then that one's on top and on and on it spins
We are not going to stop the wheel
We're going to break the wheel
Wait, what are we talking about?
hey, hey you
You must be the new guy right? Jason Thompson, pleasure
Me name's draymond of Saginaw let me introduce you to some of the guys.
We got here, Mo HouseBuckets
would as a
Baboso to Brazilian Blur we're going to be championship again and a big guy over there
That's bogut till Mountain high Kangaroo Vegemite [Savin] on the Barbie I
Ain't you newest Arm Coach Walton first lesson never drinks from me cook?
Bars over there made that mistake and they'll never drink again
Why don't [we] get jason a real drink Brandon get him what he needs get what you need?
warriors our new season [is] upon us and
Winter is coming. We we get winter in the bay area no, it's actually quite nice a lot of last year
We won 67 games
We win a thousand games or Darwin against
[weight] that would only be one game a year those men down there
They're hungry. They're hungry for our rings
But we've got to be hungrier than them
We've got [to] be crazier. I
iso
stick stance
Warriors
We will hold this war
We will hold this title
but we will hold
my dick
hello guys [that] David Lee can let me out I
brought you pull a